we're coming to this point in our  society where a large faction of people  just say who cares if it feels good it's  like uh if it makes you happy then why  the hell is it so bad yeah it's a  horrible ethos a lot of things make you  happy drugs can make you happy and they  destroy your life this person needed an  intervention this person needed someone  to say hey  cut the carbs  lower your salt and take all that stuff  go for a walk instead they said  be you strap these shoes to your feet  and bind them and then we'll put you on  a magazine ad this person's gonna die  young yeah I looked up I looked up the  definition of fat phobia on Boston  Medical  it's absolutely amazing they're like fat  phobia is deeply ingrained in systemic  racism white supremacy and misogyny it's  a typical buzzwords buzzword buzzword  buzzwords it's all garbage and lies that  that is all just absolute I have to  wonder though man